And here's my answer. It's a one-liner.
A bid in an array of 1000 things, and this is the beauty of Python.
There's ways to make it more complicated as it is before in the variance case.
Now this is a little bit more compact. So I ran the test random.random larger than 0.5.
And this thing over here gives me the true or false and I want to do this 1000 times.
And doing this 1000 times invokes this command for x in range (N) where N is 1000
and range N becomes a list of 0 to 999.
This will go 1000 times of different x's.
The x's that we've used here because the random coin flip
doesn't understand what the order of the coin flip is.
They're the same every single time but this just means I ran this procedure over here 1000 times,
collected the results in the bracketed list, and returned it.
Specifically, if we were to print out f and hit the run button then what I get is the stuff down here.
A list of 1000 items of false, true, and false. It makes for a beautiful wallpaper, doesn't it.